well would you hire a pilot who had
never flown a plane of course not Donald
Trump wouldn't either but he would hire
someone to run his campaign who has
never worked in a campaign in any
capacity at all
which leaves Republican professionals
wondering tonight now more than ever is
Donald Trump trying to crash this thing
he can hire and fire anybody he wants
from his campaign and if some are
calling it a shake off and it really is
not believe me but he is still the same
man
Banyon Kellyanne Conway this is the new
brain trust you're gonna have some sort
of remote control of whose vocal cords
the nominee is me nobody can save Donald
from Donald Bannon is really just gonna
ramp it up
this is screwing the pooch rather
royally here it's taking the campaign in
exactly the wrong direction I think
we're gonna do very well why is Trump
making these changes what does it mean
well he's making them of course he's
losing you guys are down and it shows
most of them all of them forget to staff
the most important of the candidate I am
Who I am
I don't want to change there is no new
Donald Trump this is it believe me
[Music]
this is the last word on campaign 2016
so your presidential campaign is sinking
like a stone you're losing in every
national poll and important battleground
states you're hopelessly behind ten
points behind in Pennsylvania you're on
your way to total and complete
humiliation on Election Day just 83 days
from now and so what do you do you shake
up your campaign you bring in someone
new and only only if you're Donald Trump
you hire someone for your campaign
who not only has no experience in
presidential campaigns but has never
worked in any campaign anywhere for
anything not for City Council not for
school board nothing nowhere and you
give that person a title that doesn't
really exist in presidential campaigns
CEO of the campaign Donald Trump must
have thought that was a brilliant stroke
to bring in the corporate labeling of
America to his campaign and call Steven
Bannon his campaigns new CEO Stephen
banners experience near politics has
been limited to running a right-wing
website named after its founder Andrew
Breitbart who died suddenly at age 43
four years ago hiring Steven Bannon to
run a campaign any campaign never mind a
presidential campaign is like hiring a
pilot who has never flown a plane I mean
never even flown as a passenger in a
plane it is an act of political insanity
and while he was at it Donald Trump
decided to fill the position of campaign
manager which had been vacant for two
months with someone who of course has
never been a campaign manager of any
candidate for any office anywhere
Kellyanne Conway the new Trump campaign
managers a small-time Republican
pollster who has been on the political
talk show circuit for years she has
never been a pollster in a presidential
general election but she might have been
the only person who has ever worked in
polyps
who was willing to take the job of Trump
campaign manager Paul Manafort still
holds the title of campaign chairman and
has been the boss of the Trump campaign
even though it has really operated like
a campaign with no boss Paul Manafort
has now been signed sidelined instead of
fired possibly because Donald Trump
feels that firing Manta fort would add
credibility to the already credible
reports that Manta fort may have
received millions of dollars in cash for
his political work for the president of
Ukraine Viktor Yanukovych before that
president fled Ukraine and happily took
up residence in neighboring Russia where
he is being protected by Vladimir Putin
because Vladimir Putin is obviously
still grateful that President Yanukovych
always put Vladimir Putin's interests
ahead of the interests of the people of
Ukraine here is how the new Republican
presidential campaign manager who has
never been a campaign manager outlined
her campaign strategy today this is like
a tennis match you look across the net
and you keep lobbing at her you don't
you don't pick a fight with the ref you
don't boo the crowd they're just saying
focus on her because she is Frehley yeah
it's like a tennis match in which one of
the players doesn't know where the net
is
or what a racket is here's what Hillary
Clinton said about the Trump campaign
today I think it's fair to say that
Donald Trump has shown us who he is he
can hire and fire anybody he wants from
his campaign they can make him read new
words from a teleprompter
but he is still the same man who insults
gold star families demeans women mocks
people with disabilities and thinks he
knows more about Isis than our generals
there is no new Donald Trump this is it
John has now been Shapiro former editor
at large for Breitbart news in the metro
in chief of the Daily wire also with us
Robert Costa national political reporter
for The Washington Post and MSNBC
political analyst and our Dean Forman
chairman of Democratic Party and former
Governor of Vermont
he's an MSNBC political analyst bench
Pierrot tell us about your former boss
who is now the new boss of the Trump
campaign well Steve is very volatile
character I mean he's somebody who I'm
not sure that a lot of people have dealt
with Steve who've not been screamed at
by Steve but you know that's sort of
beside the point Steve really is just a
mirror image of Trump the Titanic seems
to be going down and Trump is looking
for the nearest mirror so that he can
make sure that his hair to look it looks
good for the cameras Breitbart has been
a trump Pravda site as I said when I
quit back in March for four months now
and Steve Bannon was at the head of that
all the while presumably maintaining - a
lot of the people he was working with
that he that he was not in fact working
with or for Donald Trump it was
worthwhile mentioning here the Kellyanne
Conway who seems like a genuinely decent
person Kelly and Conway was the
spokesperson for the Mercer family the
Mercer family was the lead investor in
Breitbart and and they are also
presumably putting some money into a
Trump super PAC so that has something to
do it with with what's going on here you
know when it comes to when it comes to
what Bandhan is going to do for the
campaign I think the Ben Bannon tends to
be a Svengali figure who looks for the
nearest political celebrity latches on
to that political celebrity rides the
political celebrity like a horse and so
the horse collapses beneath him and then
moves on to the next political celebrity
to take advantage of I don't think that
that it's top priority for Bannon that
that trump win I think that he's already
achieved his goal simply by being put
this high up in the Trump campaign if
Trump wins then he gets to be in the
White House and he gets to gets all the
perks and I get I get audited by the IRS
presumably and and if Trump loses then
Bannon just moves along with Trump and
and the Breitbart site which has grown
exponentially over the last few months
thanks to their Trump support and thanks
pandering to the alt-right and then they
build a new media empire to get that be
my speculation and in the last Robert
Costa what does this mean for a Paul
Manafort Paul Manafort
remains part of the Trump campaign he's
retaining his title as campaign chairman
and chief strategist but his strategy
the argument he made to trump that's
fading within trump's inner circle that
was to professionalize the operation and
in a very straightforward way to become
more disciplined more partisan more
Republican and presentation and moving
towards Bannen you have someone who not
only is new to the national presidential
scene but is really a nonpartisan figure
he's ideological populist nationalist
and his viewpoints but he's not
associated with the Republican Party and
he shares Trump's temperament in many
ways someone who enjoys a bare-knuckle
brawl whose media savvy Howard Dean did
you have something to do with this is
this a Democratic plan to get Steve
Bannen in there as a Trump twin running
the Trump campaign is this kind of is
this exactly what the Democrats would
have liked today well I mean it's hard
to not to conclude that this is helpful
but since as you know I frequently said
I've been wrong for 52 weeks in a row
about what's gonna happen with Donald
Trump so I think it's extraordinary I
think you know Breitbart is essentially
a propagandist outfit they're somewhat
outlandish but they're successful with
their audience and so he is picking a
clone of himself I think all pretense of
actually having an on-the-ground
operation that's going to get the vote
out is going out the window I think this
is fascinating to me to see there's
there was one piece in one of the papers
an opinion piece that said this is what
is going to essentially get Drive the
RNC away and have them now make their
final commitment to abandoning Trump and
trying to save the Senate of the house
that's not implausible at this point
Robert Costa what about that the
reaction
of professional Republicans in
Washington in 1996 we saw the Republican
Party move away from Bob Dole when his
poll numbers began to dip but I think
the situation is different I spoke to
Sean Spicer the chief strategist at the
Republican National Committee today he
said he's in touch but via phone and
email with Bannon he's talking with the
Trump campaign Reince Priebus continues
to travel on the campaign trail with
Trump giving him full throated
endorsements about the party and its
support for him both financially and
politically but the pressure is coming
from Capitol Hill if you're a vulnerable
Senate strategist if you're a vulnerable
candidate in the house
this is the time where you with Bannon
and in his association with bright Bert
they're talking today to me and to other
reporters about this isn't out an exit
ramp on the highway if you are looking
to distance yourself from Trump but the
party itself RNC remains with Trump Ben
yeah I actually think and I think that's
it's not the same as Dole because Trump
has a constituency that's not inside the
Republican party if they abandoned Trump
entirely they can't afford to lose the
15 or 20 or 25 30 percent of the
electorate that's with Trump also not
the same as dual because the fact is
that Bob Dole actually cared if
Republicans lost the Senate Donald Trump
has said that he really doesn't so if
the Republicans start to pull away from
Donald Trump then Donald Trump simply
says okay I'm gonna stop raising money
for the RNC all the money disappears and
now you're really stuck between a rock
and a hard place this is the problem
with the RNC having gone along with this
ridiculous candidacy from the very
outset and now the fact that Trump has
basically made the head of his own fan
club the new campaign manager and this
is supposed to be some sort of campaign
strategy and this is this is a website
that five minutes ago was campaigning
heartily against the Speaker of the
House Paul Ryan and in favor of the of
the contender that ended up getting
shellacked in that in that particular
House primary race so this is obviously
a move by Trump to double down I thought
that I thought Charlie Sykes of
Wisconsin had a great tweet today he
said this looks like a campaign on
hospice care he's dying he's just
looking to surround friends and family
then tell people working in the Trump
campaign tonight and the Trump family
what can what they can expect now with
Steve Bannon in their offices
their lives everyday well I mean I think
I think they can expect what what they
are probably getting from Trump himself
except more volatile I mean Steve Danon
interpersonally tends to be a bully I
tend to be an authoritarian he yells a
lot none of that is any great shock I
don't think the per second and imagine
sure this bully you described and and
working under a bigger bully Donald
Trump I mean the fact is that Donald
Trump has surrounded himself with the
very best people including folks like
Paul Manafort who obviously has a shady
past in Corey Lewandowski who had
problems with with you know various
allegations of grabbing reporters of
ripe art and he surrounds himself with
the very best people by which I mean
people he likes people he trusts but not
necessarily people who are going to tell
him to do the right thing but honestly
at this point I'm not sure what from
what choice from pass I mean if you look
at Trump's campaign right now and Trump
his biggest problem is that he is Donald
Trump and he's not gonna turn into MIT
Romney nor should he attempt to and I
think what Bandhan is probably
whispering in his ear at this point is
he's just saying you know Donald now
presumably Trump presumably Trump goes
down in flames if Trump is himself since
he's been doing that for weeks now and
it's not working but bad for ban and it
works out beautifully because he gets to
be the good guy who told Trump to just
be free and fly the Lord
Lawrence I've known and covered Steve
Bannon for about six seven years and he
has this this belief and I'm sure Ben's
heard it that populism is on the rise he
embraced Sarah Palin in 2008 through
2011 when she was thinking about a White
House bid
he has always seen this grassroots
nationalistic populism as the future of
the Republican Party and so people who
spoke to him today tell me that he
thinks this is the career moment for him
he is he has suddenly seen his worldview
consumed the Republican Party with his
hands on the steering wheel and he
thinks for the next 80 days he can not
only advise Trump but try to change the
fundamental part of the Republican Party
the soul of the Republican Party toward
this Breitbart type republicanism Robert
quickly before we go what are you
hearing about morale inside the
Trump campaign those who think Trump
needs to be more Trump they're happy
with the addition of Bannon they think
Conway could help in some swing states
especially with some female voters but
the mana fort wing they think they did
all they could to put forward their
strategy and then they acknowledge
privately that it didn't click it
probably could never click Trump would
always be Trump and they're they're
they're resigned to that but they're not
exactly looking to quit they'll hang on
for Furley sometime Robert Costa ben
shapiro howard dean thank you all for
joining us tonight really appreciate
that's our thing